MARK MIRCHANDANI:
What's up, everyone.
Thanks for checking
out This Week
in Cloud, where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
March is a special month,
because it contains
one of our favorite days--
Pi Day.
In honor of the
occasion, we set out
to break the world record for
the highest number of digits
calculated and we got there--
with 31.4 trillion digits.
But in all fairness, we
had one big advantage--
Google Compute Engine.
With built-in features
like live migration,
we could continue running
the calculations non-stop
over the 118 days it
took without any downtime
for infrastructure updates.
Read about the history behind
algorithms that calculate pi
and what we had to do
differently all on the GCP
blog.
Speaking of March
Madness, Google Cloud
has teamed up with
the NCAA again
to bring big data to basketball.
If you've been looking for an
edge in your bracket this year,
try out this NCAA
BigQuery Qwiklab.
This lab gets you hands on with
BigQuery, using a huge data
set of basketball
statistics and even gets
you started building a
machine learning model capable
of making smart predictions
like your friends never could.
Try it out for
yourself and improve
your bracketology skills.
You may have heard
the recent news
about Google's
console-free game streaming
platform called Stadia.
But, even before that, the cloud
was helping to reinvent gaming.
Read about how high availability
and rapidly scalable compute,
built into GCP, allowed
multi-player breakout
hit, "Apex Legends," to reach
a whopping 50 million users
in just under a month.
Thanks to Google Cloud Platform
and open-source services
like Agones and Open Match, it's
never been easier to host games
in the cloud.
So, if you've got an idea
for the next great game,
learn how our partners
did it and let GCP help
you make your game a reality.
Our Google Doodle on March
20th celebrated JS Bach's
334th birthday,
but it also marked
another special
occasion-- the first time
AI was used a Google Doodle.
Coconet, the open-source
machine learning model,
analyzed over 300 samples
of Bach's compositions
to accurately
recreate full pieces
from only small fragments.
Check the story out to
play with the doodle
and download the model
to make some music.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.